[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
pour cette journée et tv 78 toute cette
journée aux universités des mairies aux
pyramides de port marly sur notre
plateau aux séries et d'émissions de
débat objectif 25 % le quota minimum de
logements sociaux pour les communes
franciliennes de plus de 3500 habitants
l'état donne jusqu'en 2025 pour rentrer
dans les clous fixés par la loi sru à la
solidarité et au renouvellement urbains
répond répondre à ces besoins de
logements sociaux comment fait-on
comment répondre à la pénurie quelles
solutions pour les élus et quel rôle
dans tout ça des bailleurs sociaux
c'est ce dont je vais parler avec mes
invités avec moi sur ce plateau aura
fait le cogner bonjour bonjour maire de
mantes-la-jolie vice-président de la
communauté urbaine grand paris seine et
oise et j'ajoute que vous êtes le
président du conseil de surveillance des
résidences yvelines essonne un bailleur
social qui a plus de trente et un mille
logements répartis sur les départements
des yvelines et de l'essonne
hervé lemoine bonjour m erde joueurs
pontchartrain vous êtes carences et vous
en logements sociaux on parlera de notre
outre situation dans un instant et
étienne chariot bonjour bonjour est
directeur ile-de-france de mille et une
vies habitat bailleur social qui gère
plus de 65 mille logements en ile de
france je vais commencer avec vous avec
vous quelles sont les missions de mille
et une vies habitat et quel parc de
logements sur sur le département des
yvelines
hormis les une vie habitat est un
bailleur social une société dash et lemm
qui a comme première mission de prendre
en charge les familles qui logent dans
ses 17 13 mille logements de daisy flynn
notamment et dans l'ensemble de ces
logements
donc ça c'est notre première mission
c'est d'assurer le quotidien de ces
familles qui habitent dans un logement
hlm
notre deuxième mission mais c'est
accompagner l'ensemble des institutions
et en premier lieu les maires dans le
développement du logement social pour
répondre aux besoins de la région pour
boudreau besoin d des habitants de la
région
on développe à ce point tout à l'heure
sur la suite des missions et ensuite la
suite des missions c'est d'être un
acteur dans la construction de la ville
un des acteurs de la construction de la
ville puisque nous sommes présents sur
des quartiers de façon parfois très
importante un canton et dans les
quartiers en rue quand on est à mantes
la jolie
nous sommes à un bailleur important de
mantes-la-jolie avec plus de 1013 que
1500 logements sur mantes la jolie mme
donc nous avons une part aussi dans la
construction de l'environnement et des
quartiers dans la vie du quartier au
quotidien surtout dans les quartiers
très dense commente vincent de 5000
logements en ile de france vous disiez
17 mille logements dans les yvelines sur
les rails citoyen 13,8 dans les yvelines
dans les hauts-de-seine en à 7000 on est
à plus de 20000 va presque 21 milles sur
sur les deux départements
on va parler avec vous tout à l'heure un
du rôle des bailleurs sociaux justement
dans ce contexte est de la loi sru la
situation dans vos communes respectives
d'abord messieurs à joueurs qu'on
chartrain hervé lemoine 190 logements
sociaux vous possédez 190 logements
sociaux ce qui représente un peu moins
de 10% au total sur la commune
on est bien loin des objectifs fixés par
cette loi sru comment vous expliquer
cette pénurie quels sont les freins
finalement la construction aujourd'hui
alors il ya plusieurs explications il ya
d'abord le fait qu'on a accumulé du
retard sur les mandatures précédentes
ensuite la première difficulté c'est le
coût du foncier
même si les bailleurs sociaux
aujourd'hui on bénéficie d'un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui permettent
d'abaisser le coût global d'une
opération immobilière
ça reste encore important on sait qu'il
est dans les yvelines le foncier très
cher c'est pas une c'est pas une
surprise bon c'est le principal obstacle
je dirai après c'est comment comment on
fait accepter
l'objectif de rattrapage puisque vous
citiez le chiffre de 195 jeu chiffres je
citerai un autre chiffre qui est celui
350 sais ce qu'il me reste à construire
en logements sociaux c'est inatteignable
aujourd'hui c'est totalement irréaliste
bien évidemment sauf à imaginer ce que
je ne veux surtout pas sur ma commune
c'est de faire une immense résidence
antrim et sociale de 350 logements
c'est hors de question bien entendu et
ont rappelé les sanctions prévues par la
loi sru en cas de non respect des
rythmes de construction à des sanctions
d'ordre financière un droit aussi de
préemption de l'état d'avoir une
animation s'afficher un sur ce sujet
autrement dit le préfet a le droit de
reprendre la main sur la réalisation de
ces logements sociaux
vous faites partie je le disais un des
communes carencée en termes de logements
sociaux dans les yvelines
est ce que ces sanctions sont lourdes
pour votre commune le fait de ne plus
avoir aussi la main sur sur la
construction est ce que c'est
handicapant
alors je rappelle qu'il ya trois trois
choses qui tombent sur un maire qui est
carencée en primé dans la commune de
carence est la première c'est
effectivement la perte du droit de
préemption
on l'a vécue récemment au travers de
deux préemption par l'état par les
services de l'état sur sur la commune
avec deux projets 100% sociaux donc là
il ya même pas de notion de mixité
sociale
la deuxième c'est la perte du droit de
l'attribution des logements sociaux et
la troisième c'est effectivement la
pénalité sru qui pour notre commune
aujourd'hui célèbre cent mille euros
je vous fait réagir messieurs d'abord a
fait le cogner sur le côté sanctions de
prévu par la loi sru est ce que c'est
constructif pour le coup de prévoir des
sanctions en cas de non respect pas du
tout nous inventons risque aucune
sanction puisque on est aux alentours de
40 % de logements sociaux dont je prêche
pas pour ma paroisse mais non moi je
considère que c'est une très mauvaise
idée
c'est pas des sanctions financières qui
vont aider à un maire à convaincre sa
population qu'il faut faire du logement
social et du logement social intelligent
donc je pense que ces sanctions là elles
ont l'effet inverse
elles sont plutôt à attiser les
opposants à la construction d'un
logement social plutôt qu'à faciliter
les choses donc moi j'y suis opposée
même si je pense que toutes les communes
doivent faire un effort on y reviendra
mais il ya d'autres méthodes que les
sanctions étienne charles vous êtes
d'accord c'est pas forcément constructif
alors nous on est un peu en dehors de
ces sanctions ou world du moins on
arrive justement avec un travail
partenaires
partenariat avec les maires alors éviter
ces sanctions en tout cas à mettre le
financement de ces sanctions dans des
opérations et dans des projets donc pour
nous les sanctions n'ont pas un rôle
très efficace sur la construction
puisque le partenariat la construction
d'un loft 2 d'un immeuble social prendre
des années et c'est pas c'est pas une
décision contre une sanction qui fait
qu'on arrive à travailler à construire
du logement social un jeu revient sur le
cas de mantes-la-jolie raphaël cognait
vous le disiez près de 40 % de logements
sociaux dans une telle situation c'est
quoi la politique finalement à mener ce
qu'on continue à construire du logement
social est ce qu'on rééquilibre le parc
sur la commune qu'elle est quel est
votre point de vue alors moi je
considère qu au dessus d'un certain
seuil
on se met en danger c'est à dire que
nous on a une spécificité amende c'est
que le quartier du val fourré a été
construit dans les années 70 quasiment
exclusivement logement social donc on a
un très fort déséquilibre entre la
partie social du val fourré où il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de logements sociaux
et ailleurs dans la ville où il y en a
moins donc le problème du logement
social c'est que ça rime souvent avec
logement pas très bien entretenu ça
dépend des bailleurs ça dépend des
époques mais c'est vrai qu'on a
aujourd'hui une part une part importante
de notre logement social surtout ce
qu'on pas bénéficié de l'anru 1 qui sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement dégradée donc
nous ce qu'on essaye c'est de
rééquilibrer les choses de mettre la
pression sur les bailleurs pour qu'ils
fassent leur travail de leurs travaux de
réhabilitation mais aussi de diversifier
les programmes pour que dans chaque
programme on est un petit peu de social
quand c'est nécessaire pour notamment
équilibrée des opérations août pour
participer à des opérations de
relogement parce qu'on détruit aussi
beaucoup de logements sociaux avantage
au lit et en même temps permettre des
systèmes comme le les lis comme
l'accession à la propriété pour que les
gens puissent devenir propriétaire mais
c'est compliqué de rendre des gens
propriétaire dans des endroits où il ya
énormément de logements sociaux autour
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
il suffit pas de faire trois maisons de
ville au milieu d'un parc social de 2000
logements pour qu'elle trouve
propriétaire et trouve ses maisons de
ville par exemple trouvent des acheteurs
donc il faut qu'on rééquilibre le
prévenu que ça prend du temps énormément
de temps et qu'on n'est pas forcément
aidé parce que
disons que le temps administratif n'est
pas le temps politique
et ça ça pose de gros problèmes à
l'échelle d'un mandat est-ce qu'on
rééquilibre alors ça a été déjà soulevé
comme solution on peut rééquilibrer au
niveau intercommunal certains maires ont
demandé à ce qu'on compte les logements
sociaux au niveau de l'intercommunalité
vous qui êtes vice-président a gps au il
ya la commune notamment de
flins-sur-seine un qui est concerné par
les carences est ce que vous pensez que
c'est une bonne solution en tout cas
c'est des sites envisagés pour l'avenir
moi je trouve que c'est une bonne idée
de mieux répartir les logements sociaux
à l'échelle intercommunale
après il ya des villes dans lesquelles
c'est pas possible la ville de flins par
exemple je la connais pas très bien mais
je connais bien son maire il ya des
endroits où il ya pas de foncier il ya
des endroits où le coût d'acquisition du
foncier est tellement élevé c'est comme
si vous voulez faire du logement social
à paris vous racheter des appartements à
des prix exorbitants ça me paraît pas
être la bonne solution donc il faut
qu'on répartisse mais la répartition ne
doit pas avoir pour conséquence de dire
on les met tous à certains endroits et
puis on évite certaines zones il faut
qu'on répartisse mais qu'on répartisse
entre gens qui ont envie de trouver des
compromis et que ce soit pas un prétexte
pour ne rien faire donc moi je suis
favorable à ce que entre mer on se met
d'accord sur une répartition globale
il ya des endroits où il faut qu'on
fasse baisser la part de logement social
il ya des endroits où il faut qu'elles
augmentent
j'entends aussi pour certains de mes
collègues c'est très compliqué à mettre
en place pratiquement dans leur commune
dans ce cas là il faut qu'on réfléchisse
à des compensations côté de l'amérique
noire contre chartres 1 on est sur le
même avis alors c'est un petit peu
différent parce que nous nous sommes sur
une communauté de communes oui on est à
une échelle totalement revenue avec des
petits très petites communes ça
supposerait déjà de voter un p lui ce
qu'on appelle donc impérieux
intercommunale
aujourd'hui tous les maires ne sont pas
forcément sur la même longueur d'onde
par rapport à ce projet de distribution
entre guillemets équilibrée des
logements sociaux
alors justement dans ce contexte de la
loi sru quel rôle doit g doit jouer
pardon le bailleur social et étienne
chariot ce qu'il doit être plus dans un
rôle d'incitateur d'accompagnateur de
ces communes alors nous on se place
comme rénovateur en premier lieu de nos
sites et une femme citée comme nous
avons travaillé beaucoup sur
sur mantes la jolie sur l'ensemble de
nos patrimoines donc on a plusieurs
rôles qui sont importants le premier
c'est de revoir ces quartiers qui ont
été faits dans les années 60 70 et qui
pose un véritable problème de densité et
de non mixité des populations donc on a
plusieurs chantiers on en a un énorme à
sartrouville où on détruit beaucoup de
bâtiments et on apporte de l'accession
privé pour apporter cette mixité et
inversement
dans d'autres quartiers alors à la fois
de sartrouville mais aussi de tout le
toute l'intercommunalité dont nous
apportons aussi des logements pour
pouvoir ramener de la mixité un peu
partout mais dans tous les sens notre
deuxième notre deuxième rôle est ensuite
de pouvoir travailler sur apporter
je n'ai logements là où la population
les souhaite parce que c'est pas non
plus très évident d'aller construire à
la campagne très loin des transports
puisque derrière il n'y a pas de volonté
pour la population d'aller s'installer
la base c'est loin des emplois donc un
vrai problème est une vraie
problématique de d'urbanisation et de
penser cette région parce que faut
penser au delà de la métropole à mon
sens de penser cette région dans son
urbanisation et dans sa façon de se
structurer de s'organiser
ensuite il faut aussi qu'on ait
conscience que la construction sa part
même coup partout c'est ce que ce que
vous disiez un la construction quand on
veut aller construire du logement social
à neuilly ça coûte très très cher donc
pour construire un logement associé à la
nuit eh bien on pourrait en construire
trois quatre cinq dans une grande usine
ville où le foncier est un peu moins
cher ou là où la complexité un peu plus
faible ça c'est des problématiques
politiques qui nous dépasse mais il faut
aussi qu'on réfléchisse à la façon dont
on doit développer ce logement social et
à quel coût on doit le développer vallat
le foncier aujourd'hui notre
problématique c'est le foncier qui coûte
très cher alors pour certains il est
moins cher que quand on est plus dans
paris comme vous le site y est et puis
difficilement les plus en plus
difficilement accessible ensuite les les
terrains qui reste aujourd'hui
disponibles à la vente sont de plus en
plus compliqué
soit parce qu'ils sont pas viabilisé soi
quand on est dans des communes plus
rurales soient aussi parce que quand on
est dans des communes un peu plus
proches du centre
eh bien les terrains les plus faciles à
construire ce qu'ils sont moins en pente
ceux qui ont moins de carrière en
dessous ce qui ont le moins de
contraintes techniques et si on met des
freins qui dérive de plus en plus
nombreux et puis celui qui est en train
d'apparaître depuis maintenant une année
ou deux c'est les coûts de construction
qui sont en train d'augmenter on a pris
10 à 15% dans les coûts de construction
parce que la métropole parce que le
réseau grand paris express
et parce que beaucoup d'autres chantiers
sont en sont en cours et donc la main
d'oeuvre et le et les matières premières
deviennent de plus en plus rares donc on
a vu une augmentation de 10 à 15% que ce
soit les bailleurs sociaux comme tous
les constructeurs
hervé lemoine à vos attentes vous
vis-à-vis des bailleurs sociaux quelles
sont elles
alors concernant les bailleurs sociaux
donc historiquement on a un bailleur de
référence donc effectivement je rejoins
ce que ce que monsieur disait sur les
attentes de ces bailleurs nous on essaie
de les aider mais comme l'état de
carence fait que nous n'avons plus la
main évidemment
les opportunités c'est l'état qui les
prend après je peux pas rentrer dans le
détail mais il ya une mécanique j'allais
dire administrative si je puis dire qui
concerne à la fois donc la commune qui
concerne les services de l'état qui
concerne les prix flore les filles font
peut en parler très rapidement c'est
l'établissement public foncier
d'ile-de-france qui quelque part est le
bras armé ou le bras financier de l'état
pour procéder à des acquisitions
foncières
donc tout ça se met se met en place avec
le concours du bailleur et qui permet
notamment d'ailleurs aux bailleurs de
bénéficier je dirais de dead de la part
de les fils dans la revente du foncier
au bailleur alors vous parlez d'être
justement le conseil départemental des
yvelines a par exemple voter un plan
départemental d'appui aux communes
carence l objectif combler le manque de
26 mille logements sociaux dans les
yvelines
est-ce que vous bénéficiez de ce plan et
de quelle manière on ne bénéficie pas
directement mais nous avons signé cette
convention entre guillemets avec le
département pour permettre à nos
bailleurs sociaux de bénéficier de ces
aides
par ailleurs on a signé également une
convention de mixité sociale
avec l'état et une convention de
maîtrise foncière avec les pif
donc on s'est doté à peu près tous les
outils possibles pour avancer et
rattraper le retard de plusieurs outils
mais vous le disiez les 350 logements
qui manquent on ne les atteindra pas
dissidents 25 km 25
non c'est totalement irréaliste un
dernier tour de table messieurs nous
reste quelques minutes avant de clore ce
débat répondre aux besoins de logements
sociaux ce n'est pas seulement répondre
à la pénurie c'est aussi peut être
répondre aux besoins des habitants
justement comment on change les regards
sur le logement social qui peut pâtir
parfois d'une d'une mauvaise image
comment on propose aussi un logement
social plus en adéquation avec les
enjeux climatiques qui sont actuels et
aussi la transformation digitale va
falconnier alors là dessus les bailleurs
ils ont une responsabilité qui est
colossal
parce que si on veut aider les mères à
construire du logement social il faut
que le logement social dans l'imaginaire
collectif gagnant qualité nous canton si
quelqu'un passe au val fourré y avoir
certaines parties de l'agent sociaux qui
ont été extrêmement bien réhabilité et
qui donne envie d'habiter dedans et
d'autres extrêmement dégradée donc je
comprends aussi que parfois pour les
maires surtout des maires de villages de
de petite taille ce soit très compliqué
donc première chose il faut que les
bailleurs prennent leurs responsabilités
en termes l'habitation et je dis ça
parce que ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
en tant que maire on vit quand même des
situations assez dramatique pas tous
mais ça existe
deuxième chose on a un vrai sujet dont
il faut qu'on parle c'est la question du
peuplement
il faut absolument que les maires
reprennent la main sur la question du
peuplement
tout simplement parce que le logement
social à jour pour chartres à je suis
persuadé que 90% de la population se dit
qu'elle n'y a pas droit
alors qu'en fait c'est des enfants
jouars-pontchartrain qu'on peut mettre
dans le logement social à jour pour
chartrain ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas mettre que des enfants de leur
contrat mais il faut expliquer que le
logement social n'est pas forcément
synonyme de pauvreté de gens qui
travaillent pas
non il ya beaucoup de gens qui dans le
logement social travail font enfin
vivent bien et c est donc du coup cette
question des quotas d'attribution du
peuplement de la question des
contingents elle est vraiment au coeur
de nos préoccupations de mairie parce
que c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas la
main sur cette chose là qui est une
chose absolument essentiel pour faire
accepter à long terme le logement social
troisième chose termine là dessus il
faut que les bailleurs soient plus
réactifs dans ce que j'appelle moi les
parcours de vie c'est-à-dire que nous à
menton n'a beaucoup de gens qui habitent
dans des appartements qui sont trop
grand pour eux parce que leurs familles
sont parties et à côté de ça des gens
qui vivent dans des logements trop
petits
il faut que la loi nous permettre de
faire des échanges beaucoup plus
facilement parce que c'est pas normal
qu'une maman qui a eu cinq enfants
continuent habitués dans habiter dans un
f5 et que au contraire un couple qui a
deux enfants habite dans un f2 et qu'on
puisse pas mieux adapter les choses
l'unfd surpopulation ou la
sous-occupation crée des problèmes que
nous nous avons à gérer ensuite donc cc3
mon avis sur ces trois axes qu'il faut
travailler et on n'a pas le temps d'en
parler mais je précise qu' un projet à
mantes-la-jolie sur les appartements
connectés c'est qui va voir le jour la
fin 2019 week nasa vient par les
résidences yvelines essonne ont
effectivement on a travaillé les équipes
des résidences ont travaillé sur le fait
de rendre connecter tous nos logements
neufs et la plupart en réhabilitation
pour économiser d'énergie et travailler
sur les charges et faire en sorte que
les logements soient plus sécurisés
comme en proposent
étienne sérieuses et ses logements plus
en adéquation avec les enjeux
climatiques les enjeux de la
transformation digitale
alors bien évidemment maintenant dans
toutes les constructions et dans toutes
les réhabilitations le principal axe de
travail et de travailler sur l'économie
d'énergie sur la connectivité alors
c'est plus sur la construction neuve
parce que c'est compliqué d'adapter les
bâtiments les deux bâtiments anciens en
termes de connectivité aux gars que
maintenant avec les avec les ondes ça
passe un peu mieux mais il ya toujours
quelques problèmes
ensuite pour changer l'image aussi du
logement social ce comme vous le disiez
il ya un travail à faire sur le parcours
de vie donc on a créé en à paris nous
sommes un des créateurs du ge qui permet
d'échanger d'habiter
pour que les locataires puissent avoir
accès à une plateforme où il propose de
changer leur logement pour pouvoir
s'adapter plus à leur condition en
famille et puis le principal aussi le
principal élément pour changer l'image
du duc de du logement social c'est aussi
de construire différemment et de
construire des immeubles qui s'intègre
parfaitement dans l'urbanisme de la
ville quel que soit le style de la ville
d'ailleurs mais de s'inscrire dans ce
style de la ville de de sortir de ces
bars de ces tours donc c'est vrai qu'à
sûrement à joly on a réhabilité tout
notre parc en propre avec une autre
image qui reste quand même des petits
blocs qu on a recoupé pour qu'ils sont
un petit peu moins long mais qui reste
assez linéaire dans les façades -
découpé mais c'est vrai que toutes les
constructions neuves aujourd'hui et
c'est de s'inscrire dans un dans une
architecture un peu plus à la fois
traditionnel et moderne mais plus
découpé on dire le mot de la fin très
rapidement hervé lemoine
oui alors par rapport à l'évolution
des bailleurs sociaux de choses donc
effectivement la première je confirme
que sur le plan architectural
aujourd'hui on le voit absolument pas la
différence entre de l'accession et du
social le social et parfois même plus
réussi que l'accession et puis sur
vis-à-vis de l'évolution climatique
aujourd'hui les très gros efforts qui
sont engagés par les bailleurs sociaux
merci messieurs pour votre participation
à ce débat qui touche maintenant à sa
fin mais la journée continue ici aux
pyramides de port marly 1 pour cette
université et des mairies un débat à
suivre notamment sur la place des femmes
dans la séquence qui s'annonce des
municipales 2020 un belle journée sur tv
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]